ciao ragazzi bella ragazzi potete
scaricare anche un gioco gratuito in
descrizione e l'espansione costa 14 99
completa possiamo iniziare con il video
quindi già insieme la scansione si
chiama salvatore d oulx to che il
continuo ricollega l'abbiamo fatto
l'altra volta trovate il link al video
di marco sull'altra espansione che colpo
grosso andare non sempre in descrizione
insieme ad acqua se riusciamo a tirare
fuori ma lui è
beninteso non ho proprio sì però solo
tutti loro che sono in altre porte
capisca valore dolcezza si aspetta che
c'è una roba strana in testa perché sei
sudato non sudare capitolino la città
perduta giochiamo una era giustamente no
ha dato carica allora scegliamo l'unico
che abbiamo riconosciuto di euro per
ogni 30 gex sono pi classe tra l'altro
doppia classe il mago l'altro ci manca
il figlio allora non sono sicuro di
della nostra bravura perché insieme
siamo i campioni italiani per l'ultima
volta abbiamo supportato stato veramente
va bene che lui è una delle mie carte
profeti quando muore per verissimo tela
dovrebbero far doppiare una carta che
con genere lui così sto fermo e zitto
che poi ricordiamoci che le prime ali
erano un po si può esatto quindi prima
volta che la realizzarlo allineare nei
ragazzi questo video durerà molto poco
perché siamo stati io comunque voglio
vorrei ricordare i ragazzi che
l'obiettivo è una cagata ora che sta
dicendo però per chi non lo conoscesse
l'obiettivo è far arrivare a zero la
vita dell'avversario e non far arrivare
a zero la nostra mente quindi se
l'obiettivo deve essere sempre non
perdere su un campo oro settimana
catalitica filo rosa ha scelto questo un
muro come un voto da luned ora piove
altro knox evoca it è servito il
bellissimo premio neanche uno
dopo il prodotto è calato all m buon
bene allora
bravo sì non avevo più salato starò ma
attacca lui bravissimo poi vocali ma
bravissimo questo volume è stata molto
più bravo
ho vissuto la mente il costo di queste
blog beh ragazzi questa casta è molto
difficile ma infatti bros e vi ricordo
che mi darà molto più difficile cruda
non aver mai siamo sul finale che viveva
prendi dal gusto e facciamolo volevo
fare business atto ma si riprende quando
mi aspetto è mai per questo turno ok no
facciamo così guarda chi l'ha detto
corretta perché il turno dopo gliela do
a lui che vale il 2 diventa pure p4
ritorno dopo secondo me non esiste tra
un po e invece vero centro claudio
andamento non ne può più non abbiamo la
più bella più
non è vero no non è vero ok dal cappello
alla tipo micro rimini la carta in mano
eliminare la prima amichevole per in
assoluto rinviene una carta del mago
casuale poi l'angolo la non messa in
guai maledizione di mettete la nostra
vita mentre siamo bravissimi mio broker
es la prima è stato veramente
immagino di sì abbiamo visto abbiamo
vinto so che non ci meritiamo ma abbiamo
bambino
[Musica]
bye bye bye bye bye ma occhio alla gara
no non ce l'aveva 2 3 4 5 6 set una
donna e una forma dopo che lanciato
immagino un turno umbraco 55 d'attacco
pare la tua armatura un po per quanto
riguarda più 4 giu la messa il visore il
mio dovere quella delle magie perché
siamo messi veramente incredibili la
metti d'olen turno dopo come quella da 1
e poi lancia la magia che ne pensi
questo questo turno è stato inferiore
per un'ora e mezza troppo assurdo allora
cosa che puoi fare è tornano metti
questo subito blu già fattura cagato
perché non abbiamo magia ne abbiamo tre
per questo ho fatto io poi l'ho ripigli
in mano perché tanto non ti ha fatto
fuori quella sempre che non si danno a
dare adesso cosa molto probabile abito
di attacco di giada donna
dalla pro meno 6 danni seri pd va
benissimo che orribile ingrana lo
stupido e di nuovo anche di fini nella
sala madonna con assalto pro ma possiamo
18345 mi ci servirebbe da molo vii
mannaia il danno la7 da 97 non va bene
allo stesso fissati a me questo film
[Musica]
ok ma io non ci posso credere andato su
di lui due volte pazzesco abbiamo vinto
vai dritto contro nessuno lui non potrai
mai abbia momento però abbiamo vinto
solo perché gli andato due volte in
gioco quanto fosse fidarci a verona su
sette e una su sette di nuovo quindi uno
sportello
secondo me possiamo contro l'ultimo
posto tra via fatta nel muro e positivo
che è molto piccola già conserva niente
in questa volta noi ci vediamo qui in
questo video arma facciamo vincere
questa partita ma poi immune cosa ci
rimane molto da cosa soprattutto un buon
lo commuove quindi sul muro questi due
ci facciamo se uno perde 3 salute dopo
che è morto un muro quindi tu li puoi
fare niente niente proceduto lui mi levi
18 ma anche lui ho capito ma se avevano
una carta che eleva 18 aspetta mister
eroi dc usa il potere per fartela fuori
un sapete da che parte da fuori per
l'amor di dio
stai solo eliminando i deboli
non ho capito ma possiamo fare così
faccio un trucco ma si abbandona in base
a che cosa mi toglieranno hai voluto che
muoiono quanto danno quanto hanno loro
dall'oliva lui oltre a quelli tra in
volta quindi 2333 possibile non
arriveremo mai alla fine ma non puoi
quartiere di far fuori di fare quel
cento move lo devi fare fuori centro
murlo 100 100 pubblico ok userei andata
[Musica]
a trovare il gioco per dirlo labbra
diventato fuori dall immune a questo su
google chrome ogni 100 tolti a una roba
diverso io sono imbarazzato non abbiamo
strategia di trovare qua da a batterci
con l'età si lo so bene perché parte di
far fuori anche lui alla fine il tuo
turno
ormai si vive fuori muro che non si fa
più danno quindi occhio chiuso messi bar
è uguale provai fuori il 22
al 33 poi quello 0 1 che cosa si potrà
prepararsi trasferiti gli ambienti
[Musica]
ecco quando bisognava usare queste aree
l'america saperlo dopo quante carte ha
così a decreti non ha evocato niente
così hai detto il cretino e si è accesa
alexa purtroppo non trovo limare a
fermarlo con il sonno dopo giorno
abbiamo perso però è resa dalla primo
momento era gaza da quando ha fatto una
roba lì non possiamo c'è qualcosa
[Musica]
amico mi sarei tolto anche un giocatore
della sampdoria
ma c'è chi pensava la sampdoria 20
secondi fa te lo giuro
te lo giuro perché pensavo alla juve che
arriva sempre in finale poi perde come
noi pensa quindi non secondo voglio
venderlo se io anche ma non posso finire
studio depresso per tirarmi su
tranquillo ora andiamo a mangiare sul
suo peso di mano ai ragazzi a parte gli
scherzi trovate arson in descrizione e
ovviamente gratis trovata la nova
espansione che ai salvatori di youtube e
che la prima il primo libertà la prima
da un quadro di quadro il primo quadro è
gratis
the arrivate almeno a un tutti i
personaggi vincente anche una busta che
noi abbiamo vinto ma da sudare
allora è riuscita a battere porta piaga
ma dovevo come direct perché sì perché
incredibile ragazze non ho veramente a
partiti mandatemi dai l'ex è riuscita a
battere l'ultimo boss perché veramente
pazzesco e noi ci vediamo al prossimo io
ringrazio marco ti iscrivi al canale
passate anche la sua ragazza
[Musica]